A GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT. OUT WE ARE GONNA GET
UNDER WAY.
UNNOTICED PRESENCE OF.
SO REMEMBER HARPER WILL BE
PRESENTING AT THAT ME SAY RIGHT
AT THE TOP THAT AB TWO EIGHT ONE
BY SOLACE.
HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING SCHEDULE AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR SO IF YOU HEAR FOR
AB TWO EIGHTY ONE OF THAT BILL
WILL NOT BE HURT DAY.
LET US.
OFFERS A WELCOME.
SOME NEW MEMBERS.
TO OUR COMMITTEE UP FIRST WE
WANNA WELCOME A PERMANENT MEMBER
TO THE COMMITTEE WE ARE HONORED
TO WELCOME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ TO THE
LABOR COMMITTEE WELCOME WELCOME.
AND WE'RE HAPPY AYE FOR TODAY
ONLY.
ALTHOUGH HE'S WELCOME COME BACK
ANYTIME HE WISHES TO NOW WE'RE
HAPPY TO WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KANSEN CHU.
WHO WILL BE HERE TODAY?
UP WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THURMAN.
HERE FLORA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER RATHER KALRA THEIR
CHU.
MELENDEZ.
CORNERSTONE. WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
SO WILL GET UNDERWAY.
WILL FIRST CALL ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HARPER TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE.
WELCOME SOME MEMBER HARPER
.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WOULD ALLOW RETAILERS
EMPLOYEES FLEXIBILITY FOR
CHOOSING.
TO WORK FOUR TEN HOUR DAYS OR
THE TRADITIONAL FIVE EIGHT HOUR
DAYS DURING THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
WHICH RUNS FROM NOVEMBER FIRST
TO JANUARY THIRTY FIRST.
THE HOLIDAYS ARE A TIME FOR
FAMILIES TO COME TOGETHER GIVE
THANKS AND CREATE MEMORIES.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE A FULL ARE A
WORK TO WORK A FULL SCHEDULE. IT
LEAVES LITTLE TIME AFTER WORK TO
SHOP FOR PRESENTS CqC HOLIDAY
MEALS.
OR HAVE FUN WITH THE FAMILY.
CALIFORNIA'S ANTIQUATED LABOR
STANDARDS.
DO NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY FOR HARD WORKING
PEOPLE OR RETAILERS.
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF ONLY THREE
STATES THAT DOES NOT CONFORM TO
THE FEDERAL FAIR LABOR STANDARDS
ACT.
OVERTIME REQUIREMENTS.
RETAILERS CURRENTLY HAVE TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH A BURDENSOME
PROCESS.
TO LET EMPLOYEES TO HAVE A
FLEXIBLE WORK WEEK.
IF A MISTAKE IS MADE DURING THE
PROCESS
RETAILERS HAVE TO PAY COSTLY
OVERTIME WAGES.
MY BILL WOULD ELIMINATE COSTS
AND THE BURDENS RETAILERS FACE
IN ADOPTING. A FLEXIBLE WORK
WEEK SCHEDULE FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES DURING THE HOLIDAY
SEASON.
FOR EMPLOYEES WERE LOOKING TO
EARN MONEY EXTRA MONEY DURING
THE SEASON FLEXIBLE SCHEDULING
WOULD GIVE THEM AN EXTRA DAY TO
WORK A SECOND JOB. WITHOUT
HAVING TO JUGGLE MULTIPLE SHIFTS
IN A COURT IN A SINGLE DAY.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE HELPS
CALIFORNIA MODERNIZE ITS LABOR
LAWS
TO BENEFIT EVERYONE. I
RESPECTFULLY OSCAR AYE VOTE AND
WITH ME HERE TODAY.
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE IS LARA CURTIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER COMMERCE.
AND FAITH CLAIM WITH THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY THE FORTIETH ME
WITNESSES.
A LOT OF WHAT AFTER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HARPER SAID WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BECAUSE EMPLOYEES ARE
CONSISTENTLY ASKING FOR A FEW
MORE FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THEIR
WORK WEEK.
THEY WANNA WORK LONGER DAYS AND
SHORTER WEEKS IN ORDER SPEND
MORE TIME WITH THEIR FAMILY AND
ORDERED A COMEDY CLASS SCHEDULES
OR IN ORDER TO ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL EMPLOYMENT HOWEVER I
SIGNED SENATE ARE AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HARPER SAT.
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF ONLY THREE
STATES THAT HAS THE DAY OF THE
OVERTIME REQUIREMENT THE OTHER
TWO STATES THAT HAVE THIS
REQUIREMENT ALLOWING EMPLOYEE
AND EMPLOYER TO ESSENTIALLY
WE'VE THE REQUIREMENT. BY MUTUAL
AGREEMENT CALIFORNIA HAS NO
COMMON SENSE ALTERNATIVE RATHER
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES AN EMPLOYER
TO NAVIGATE THEMSELVES THROUGH A
MULTI STEP PROCESS WHEREBY AN
ENTIRE WORK UNIT MUST VOTE BY A
TWO THIRDS VOTE. IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE AND.
IN ORDER TO ADOPT AN
ALTERNATIVE WORK WEEK SCHEDULE
ADDITIONALLY THERE NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT EXPOSE THE
EMPLOYER TO POTENTIAL OF LEFT
HAND LIABILITIES.
HOWEVER AB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
WOULD ALLOW AN EMPLOYER A LITTLE
BIT MORE IN THE WAY JUST DURING
THE HOLIDAY SEASON BETWEEN
NOVEMBER AND JANUARY IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE THEIR EMPLOYEES
REQUEST.
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO DISCUSS AND
NEGOTIATE AND UPON WRITTEN
APPROVAL VOCAL BY EITHER PARTY
AT ANY TIME THE ABILITY TO
ACCOMMODATE A FLEXIBLE WORK WEEK
SCHEDULE THAT IS WHY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THEY PLAYED WITH THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MISS CURTIS IN
THE CHAMBER AND ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT THERE ARE OVER A MILLION
FAMILY BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT EMPLOYEE SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. THAT THE BACKBONE
AND THE HEART OF THE ECONOMY OUR
MEMBERS OFTEN REPORT THAT THEY
WANT FLEXIBILITY WHETHER IT'S TO
CHANGE A LUNCH HOUR TO MAKE
THEIR CHILD'S LITTLE LEAGUE
GAMES OR TO SPEND EXTRA TIME.
WITH A CHILD THAT'S HOME FROM
COLLEGE FOR THE HOLIDAYS SADLY
OUR PLAYERS HAVE TO BE THE BAD
GUYS AND TELL THEM THAT STATE
LAW PROHIBITS BY.
AND OUR MEMBERS OWN FAMILY
BUSINESSES BUT THEY ALSO LIKE TO
TREAT THEIR MEMBERS LIKE FAMILY
AND THIS BILL GIVES THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO JUST THAT
ESPECIALLY DURING THE HOLIDAYS
WHEN THAT EXTRA FAMILY TIME IS
IMPORTANT. FOR THAT WE ARE PROUD
TO BE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
HI ANGIE MINNELLI WAS CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO KITTY HAVE SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION PARENTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON AND
SUPPORT.
I'VE SEEN NONE WILL NOT HEAR
FROM OUR THE OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL.
BILL HAS SOME MOTION IS OUR
SECOND.
BILLS MOVED AND SECONDED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ARE HERE TO IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. FOR THE
PRIMARY REASON THAT IT'S
UNNECESSARY GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA
ALREADY GIVES EMPLOYERS A WAY TO
DO THIS WE HAVE. OUTLINED IN
LABOR CODE SECTION FIVE ELEVEN
AND ALTERNATIVE WORK WEEK
SCHEDULE PROCESS THAT.
VERY CLEARLY ALREADY ALLOWS
EMPLOYERS TO ASK WORKERS IF THEY
WANT TO GO TO SAY FOR TENS AND
THERE'S A PROCESS THERE THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO DO THIS. THROUGH
ELECTION TWO THIRDS OF WORKERS
HAVE TO AGREE THERE'S CLEAR
LANGUAGE IN THE RAGS THAT
PROHIBIT EMPLOYERS FROM
INTIMIDATING OR THREATENING
WORKERS THAT. MAKE SURE IT'S A
FAIR PROCESS THAT WORKERS.
THEIR WORKERS CAN PARTICIPATE
IN AND WAY AND WE CAN GET A ON
THE ACCU WILL ABSORB AND ACTUAL
HONEST READ ON WHETHER OR NOT
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEES WANT TO GO TO
SAY FOR TENS.
SO THE PROCESS EXISTS BUT I
THINK THERE'S BEEN ABOUT THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND OF THESE
ELECTIONS SINCE THE LAW'S BEEN
IN PLACE. ARM AND YOU WE THINK
THE PROCESS GENERALLY WORKS
PRETTY WELL THERE'S REALLY NO
REASON TO WEAKEN IT WHICH. IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
KIND OF TAKES A LOOK AT THE
ALTERNATIVE WORK WEEK SCHEDULE
PROCESS AND. TAKES OUT
EVERYTHING IN IT THAT WORKS FOR
WORKERS SO THAT TWO THIRDS
REQUIREMENT IS GONE. INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS CAN BE PRESSURED INTO
MAKING THIS DECISION THERE THERE
IS SOME LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT SEEKS TO. PROHIBIT
EMPLOYERS FROM THREATENING OR
INTIMIDATING WORKERS BUT THERE'S
REALLY NO WAY TO ENFORCE THEM
AND THE FACT THAT THERE AREN'T
ANY STANDARDS THAT PROHIBITS
SAY.
THESE MEETINGS FROM HAPPENING
ONE ON ONE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
IN REALITY MEANS THAT WORKERS
WOULD BE PRESSURED INTO AGREEING
TO THINGS LIKE THIS ON MORE THIS
TO ACTUALLY BE IN PRACTICE.
AND FURTHER MORE THE AT THE FACT
THAT IT TARGETS NOVEMBER
DECEMBER AND JANUARY. SEEM
ESPECIALLY PUNITIVE TO US GIVEN
THAT THIS IS WHEN WORKERS COSTS
TEND TO RISE GIVEN THAT THIS IS
WHEN THE HOLIDAYS HAPPEN THIS IS
WHEN YOU NEED TO TRAVEL THIS IS
WHEN FAMILIES COMING INTO TOWN.
IN WORKERS IF ANYTHING NEED
MORE MONEY RATHER THAN SEEING
THEIR OVERTIME PROTECTIONS
ELIMINATED UNDER THE LAW AND SO
THESE A VARIETY OF OTHER REASONS
WE WOULD URGE OPPOSITION OF THIS
FILM.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF BROUGHT INVESTMENT
LLP.
WE REPRESENT THE TEAMSTERS THAT
NOW THE MAIN TRANSIT UNION AND.
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS UNITE
HERE THE LONGSHOREMEN I'M AYE OF
P. T. LOCAL TWENTY ONE WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR SOME BROWN OF
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS HERE IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL WE ARE TO KNOW VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG OPPOSITION WE ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THE LABOR
FEDERATION.
THANK YOU.
CENTER BARRERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
Q. ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HALF A
QUESTION.
SOME MEMBERS ARE ANY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. AYE I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY READ THE BILL YOU KNOW I'M
INTERESTED I LEARNED A LOT FROM
THE ANALYSIS SONY THINKS BECAUSE
COURSE COMING FROM ORGANIZED
LABOR I WOULD TELL YOU OF COURSE
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY YOU CAN
ALLOW YOUR WORKERS TO.
VOLUNTARILY JOIN A UNION AND
NOT INTIMIDATE OR HARASS THEM
AND THEN THEY COULD. ACTUALLY
NEGOTIATE A FLEXIBLE WORK WEEK.
BUT NOW I KNOW THAT THERE'S
THIS TWO THIRDS ELECTION THAT I
NEVER KNEW EXISTED ACTUALLY
AMOS'S SO THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING AS WELL ANOTHER
PROVISION BY WHICH.
EMPLOYEES CAN ASSERT IF THEY
WOULD LIKE THEIR RIGHT TO
FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULES IN A
MENU OF FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULE
SO WOULDN'T HAVE TO BE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL. SO I THINK THERE
IS FLEXIBILITY BUT OF A QUESTION
ON WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO AMEND
IN IN YOUR BILL.
A CERTAIN NUMBER PROVISIONS
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE LOOKING OUT
FOR THE WORKER AND THEIR
FLEXIBILITY.
DO YOU THINK THERE SHOULD BE A
PROVISION FOR.
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO.
TO.
REJECT WORKING ON HOLIDAYS.
WITHOUT ANY REPERCUSSIONS IN
FACT PROTECTING OTHER SCHEDULES
THERE OTHERWISE SCHEDULES E. ON
TO THEIR JOB IF THEY REFUSE TO
WORK FOR EXAMPLE ON THANKSGIVING
AT WALMART OR CHRISTMAS IT
DONALD'S.
I THINK THAT THOSE ARE.
.
YOU KNOW VERY PERTINENT THAT
TOPIC SAID INTO THE LEGISLATURE
BUT PROBABLY NOT GERMANE
DIRECTLY TO THE BILL ITSELF IN
PROBABLY WOULD BE A GOOD TO VOTE
ON INDEPENDENTLY AS THEIR OWN.
BUT THE REASON STATED FOR THE
BILL IS TO PROVIDE EMPLOYEES
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY SO THAT
THEY CAN ENJOY A HOLIDAY
SHOPPING. COOKING FOR THEIR
KIDS.
BUT THAT SEEMS.
COUNTER. IF IF IN FACT THEY
CAN'T EVEN BE HOME WITH THEIR
KIDS ON THE HOLIDAYS AT THEIR
OWN CHOOSING.
WELL IN IS THIS DOES IS IT
ALLOWS FOR A WRITTEN AGREEMENT
TO BE BETWEEN THE EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE AND SO THAT'S EASILY
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE INTEREST IN TERMS OF
WHAT ARE THOSE DAYS WHICH WERE
THE DAYS IN WHICH THE EMPLOYEE.
I. HAS OFF BECAUSE THAT'S THE
WHOLE IDEA IS TO BE ABLE HOW THE
FLEX TIME BY TO ALLOW THE TEN
HOUR DAYS TO ACCOMMODATE THOSE
DAYS OFF. AND SO SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE BY
THE EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONSHIP BY DIRECTLY FIRE
STAND I UNDERSTAND THE POINT A
POINT THAT YOU HAVE AND I THINK
THAT THIS.
THIS UP ALLOWS FOR. EMPLOYEES
TO BE MORE EMPOWERED TO
NEGOTIATE ON BEHALF OF
THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WELL I AM I STRONGLY DISAGREE
AND IF YOU SEE ANY.
OR OR MAYBE TOUCH YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AS AS I DO ALWAYS
AROUND THE HOLIDAY TIME ON ON
THIS ISSUE.
YOU'LL KNOW THAT THEIR NUMBER
OF EMPLOYERS IN FACT TO HOTEL
EMPLOYEES AND ACTUALLY POSTED TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES THAT IF THEY.
EVEN ATTEMPTED TAKE A LEGALLY
PROTECTED SICK DAY DURING THE
HOLIDAYS THAT THEY WILL LOSE
THEIR JOB.
AND SO I I A.
THINK THAT MY EXPERIENCE IN WORK
PLACES PARTICULARLY IN RETAIL
AND RESTAURANTS IN AND AND
DEALING WITH THE WORKERS ARE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THERE'S NO.
I'M ABILITY FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO
NEGOTIATE THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCE WITH THE EMPLOYER
AND THIS.
BILL DEFINITELY DOESN'T GIVE
THE EMPLOYEE ANYMORE RIGHTS OR
ABILITY TO RETAIN THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AND TO RETAIN THEIR
SCHEDULING TO RETAIN. AND THEIR
POSITION A WORKPLACE IF THEY
WERE TO TRY TO HAVE THOSE EVEN
ATTEMPT HAVE THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
SO I'M GONNA.
VOTE NO TODAY AND I AND AND
SUGGEST THAT IF EMPLOYERS ONE
COME FORWARD WITH IDEAS ABOUT
FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULES AND
SECURE WHAT'S WORK SCHEDULES AND
WORKING WITH EMPLOYEES TO.
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE MOST
AMOUNT OF RIGHTS POSSIBLE THAT
WOULD BE GREAT DISCUSSION TO
HAVE TOGETHER.
INTO REALLY RESPECT
WORKERS IN THE RIGHTS TO BE WITH
THEIR FAMILIES DURING THE
HOLIDAY OF SOME OF THE VOTING
NOW.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
THAT YOUR POINT OF VIEW I JUST
RESPECT
WE DISAGREE. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS.
SOME REMEMBER MENENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU SETTLEMENT HARPER FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THIS BILL I AM
I THINK THERE ARE SOME. VERY
VALID CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
OUT ABOUT THIS BILL PARTICULARLY
WITH PROTECTION OF THEM OF
EMPLOYEES HOWEVER.
JUST AS.
ONE SUGGEST THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME INTIMIDATION THAT TAKES
PLACE IN TRYING TO. COERCE
WORKERS IN IT YOU KNOW I'M
ACCEPTING A PARTICULAR. WORK
SCHEDULED THE WEEK THERE'S
THERE'S.
THAT ALSO EXISTS.
IF YOU HAD THE OPTION OF OF A
MENU FROM WHICH TO CHOOSE SO THE
THAT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE AN
ISSUE THAT CAN BE DEALT WITH IN
A IN A LEGAL WAY.
.
THROUGH THROUGH THE LIES IN
PLACING THE REGULATORY SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE WHAT I.
WHAT I KNOW IS THAT PARTICULARLY
DURING HOLIDAYS?
IS WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR WORK ARE HOPING. TO
BE HIRED BECAUSE THEY NEED THE
EXTRA CASH I'M OR THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY EMPLOYED. THERE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THE EXTRA HOURS
DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO WORK
ANOTHER DAY THAT WEEK BUT WOULD
CERTAINLY ENJOY THE HOURS AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S A.
A NEGOTIATION THAT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TAKE PLACE BETWEEN THE
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE SOME MAY
NOT WANT TO DO THAT AND OTHERS
MAY CHOOSE TO DO THAT I KNOW I
HAVE A SON. WHO?
WHO WORKS AT HE STILL IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND DURING THE HOLIDAYS
HE WANTS TO MAKE SOME MONEY AND
HE WANTS TO MAKE SOME? YOU KNOW
WORK SOME EXTRA HOURS A HE'S
YOUNG HE DOESN'T MIND WORKING A
TEN HOUR DAY AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE BY THE WAY YOU DO WORK
TEN HOUR DAYS AND THOUGH. MANY
OF THEM ARE.
MANY OF THEM ARE UNIONIZED.
BUT.
SOMEONE SOMEONE WORK IS OUR SOME
DON'T I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
THE OPTION I THINK WHEN WE TAKE
THAT OPTION AWAY. FROM EMPLOYEES
AND EMPLOYERS THAT AND WE WERE
GOING FURTHER DOWN THE PATH OF
MAKING EMPLOYEES MORE
SUBSERVIENT TO THE STATE WHICH
IS CERTAINLY NOT WHAT WE WANT TO
DO SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR TO
BILL T!I THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER CALLED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SAME HARPER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
I THINK THAT TO SUGGEST THAT A
WORKER IS IN THE SAME BARGAINING
POSITION AS AN INDIVIDUAL. WITH
AN EMPLOYER IS JUST NOT REALITY
AND AND PARTICULARLY DURING THE
HOLIDAY SEASON JUST BECAUSE.
SOMEONE IS SEEKING ACTUAL PLAN
INNER EXTRA RESOURCES EXTRA CASH
IN THE HOLIDAYS WHATEVER
WHATEVER REASON.
IN NO WAY MEANS THAT THEY DON'T.
DESERVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY IN
THE SAME RIGHTS TO BE ABLE.
TO.
.
THE COMPENSATOR PROPERLY AND I
KNOW THAT THIS BILL WOULD.
A ESSENTIALLY ALLOW FOR TEN HOUR
WORK DAYS WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY
OVERTIME AND WE DO HAVE A
CURRENT PROCESS REQUIRES. A MORE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
AND THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT
AND I THINK THAT.
IT THERE IS TRULY CONCERN
REGARDING THE HOLIDAYS AND
ALLOWING WORKERS STEP PERHAPS IS
A TO SPEND TIME THEIR FAMILY I
HOPE. I WOULD HOPE MORE
RETAILERS WOULDN'T REQUIRE THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO WORK ON
THANKSGIVING AND WORK ON OTHER
HOLIDAYS LIKE THEY DO NOW.
THAT'S TRULY THE HOLIDAY SPIRIT%
AND SO.
I'VE UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR
PROSPECTIVE I DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY. OF AND I
BUT I DO HOPE THAT WILL CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION A SPECIAL WITH
OUR RETAILERS AND AND EMPLOYERS
AS TO HOW WE COULD INSURE.
THAT WORKERS ARE RESPECTED.
DURING THE HOLIDAY SEASON SO
THAT THEY CAN SPEND MORE TIME
WITH OUR LOVED ONES.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SPICER.
JEFF OKAY STATE.
.
I'LL ASK JUSTICE WIND IT WAS
ADDRESS A NUMBER OF TIMES THAT
EMPLOYEES COULD.
OF FEEL BULLIED INTO.
YOU WORKING IT'S TIME TO THAT
IT WON'T WORK.
STARBRIGHT LIKE THAT YOU'D
ADDRESS THAT DIRECTLY BECAUSE
I'M SENSITIVE TO THAT AND IF
THAT IS THE CASE I WOULD NOT
WANNA PUT WORKERS IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY WILL BE VULNERABLE.
ONTO ESSENTIALLY EARNING LESS
MONEY AND WORKING ON A MORE
DIFFICULT CONDITIONS WOULD YOU.
I THINK THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT
WHAT WE BUILT INTO THIS BILL IS
THE THE AGREEMENT THE CONTRACT
AYE AND THAT CONTRACT IS
VOIDABLE BY THE EMPLOYEE AT ANY
TIME. AYE AND SO YOU HAVE A
SITUATION I THINK HERE WHERE
EMPLOYEES ARE I CAN BE PROTECTED
AND BE ABLE TO DECIDE AGAINST
THIS IF THEY CHOSE TO DO THEIR
SIDE IT.
AND ANY TIME I THINK THAT
PROVIDES FOR THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT THAT I'M THAT I'M SEEKING
AND I THINK THAT A LOT OF
EMPLOYEES. ARE SEEKING WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND TO
THE POINT THAT THERE IS ALREADY
A SYSTEM IN PLACE FOR HOW.
EMPLOYEES CAN.
RECEIVE A FLEXIBLE WORK
SCHEDULE THAT SEEMS TO HAVE
BUILT IN.
CAPTION FROM ANYONE EMPLOYEE
BEING SINGLED OUT BECAUSE IT IS
OF VOTE AS OPPOSED TO A
INDIVIDUAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
MANAGER AT WOULD YOU ALL SPEAK
TO THAT.
I IF I CAN I THINK SHE HAS THE
EXPERTISE TO PLACE MORE MORE
ARTICULATELY AND I'M MORE
ACCURATELY I ANSWER THAT
QUESTION YES THE MODEL RIGHT NOW
IS ESSENTIALLY MORE OF A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
WHO DOESN'T APPROACH
INDIVIDUALIZE NEAT SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS IN LET'S SAY MOM.
WANTS TO HAVE EVERYONE SEE OFF
BECAUSE OUR TOP WITHOUT A
MINIMUM DAY THIS DOESN'T
APPROACH THAT NEED WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT IT MUST BE A TWO THIRDS
VOTE BY THE ENTIRE WORK UNIT
WHICH COULD BE LET'S SAY ALL
SECRETARIES OF COURSE IN THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY IT WOULD BE. YOU
KNOW ALL MAKE A COUNTER PLEASE
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT THEY'VE
TO VOTE BY A TWO THIRDS VOTE
ADDITIONALLY THERE HAS TO BE A
FOURTEEN DAY NOTICE PRIOR TO THE
VOTE. IN ORDER TO NOTIFY ALL
EMPLOYEES AT THE VOTE'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IN ORDER FOR IT TO PASS THE NEW
EMPLOYEES HAVE TO AGREE ON AN
ALTERNATIVE WORK SCHEDULE OR AS
A MENU OF OPTIONS HOWEVER THERE
ARE ALSO DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS. AND TO NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE EMPLOYERS
HAVE TO ABIDE BY IN ORDER TO NOT
I'M A BIT EXPOSED LITIGATION
THEN ONCE THAT OCCURS THEN IS
POST ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR'S WEBSITE HOWEVER THERE'S
NO REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
EVEN ONCE IT'S POSTED. THAT THE
EMPLOYER HAS DONE IN A PROPER
MANNER SO THEREFORE IT'S EVEN
MORE EXPOSED LITIGATION. SO THE
ISSUE WITH THAT IS THAT THERE'S
NO INDIVIDUALIZED OPTION FOR ONE
EMPLOYEE TO COME AND SAY I OULD
LIKE TO NOT WORK.
ON WEDNESDAYS I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THREE TEN ARE FOUR TEN HOUR
DAYS AND FORTY WORK FORTY HOUR
WORK WEEK.
THANK YOU OF THE BILL HAS A
MOTION AND A SECOND AYE I'LL SAY
THIS I.
APPRECIATE THE LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE THAT YOU BROUGHT TO
THIS CONVERSATION IN THE
ARGUMENTS THAT YOU ARE MAKING TO
TRY AND SUPPORT WORKERS. AYE
I'LL SAY THIS IS CHAIR I
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE CONCERN OF
THAT MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION AT
THIS TIME WOULD MAKE WORKERS
VULNERABLE. ARE FOR THOSE
REASONS ARE FORTUNATE I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AYE AND
THE BILL HAS A AS A NO
RECOMMENDATION. UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THAT BUT IF I'M
SORRY WE LEFT IT CLOSE SORRY I
WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST TEEING
IT UP SO. I APPRECIATE WEEKLY
PUSH BACK ON EVERYTHING THAT I
JUST SAID THAT THIS ISSUE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME I'VE
WORKED.
VARIOUS HOURLY JOBS UP OVER MY.
I WAS AT DOMINO'S PIZZA MY
SECOND JOB WAS A KMART MY THIRD
JOB WHICH AGAIN IS FOR MORE THE
TAXI TO SHOP AT THE LOCAL MALL.
FIVE BY DAY EVEN AS RECENTLY AS
LAST GET DECADE I WORKED A LONG
TERM AYE AT THE HONDA CENTER
WHICH IS THE.
UP ARENA AND.
IN HOCKEY.
LOCATION IN ORANGE COUNTY AYE
AND.
WORKING DURING THE HOLIDAYS AYE
IS A FOR ME IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
PARTICULARLY EXCITING TIME TO BE
A PART OF US. OF ALL THE
EXCITEMENT THAT PEOPLE HAVE I
AND I'VE HAD A PARTICULARLY
POSITIVE SITUATION WITH
EMPLOYERS THAT I'VE HAD WHICH I
HAVE ALWAYS REACHED OUT WHEN
THEY WANTED YOU TO WORK DURING
THOSE UP.
PARTICULAR HOLIDAYS WERE
ADJACENT TO THE PARTICULAR
HOLIDAYS BUT THEY DID THINGS TO
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE WANTED TO
BE ABLE COME OUT TO WORK BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT THE ABSENTEEISM
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE. AYE
TO SHOW UP AND BE MOTIVATED TO
TO SHOW UP UP BUT I ALSO
UNDERSTAND. HOW SOME PEOPLE MAY
BE TRYING TO JUGGLE TWO JOBS OR
THREE JOBS SIMULTANEOUSLY IN
THIS CAN HELP THAT KIND OF
SITUATION OR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
BE ABLE TO SAVE? AYE TIME FOR
THEMSELVES I I THINK THAT THIS
PROVIDES A GREATER AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES AYE AND I'D REALLY
LIKE TO LET EVERYONE TO I
RESPECTFULLY CONSIDERATE NOW ASK
FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE THE LAST WORD
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN NO
THURMAN NO FLORA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTAKEN.
THANK YOU.
OF THE COMMITTEE WELCOMES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE WHO WAS
PRESENT IN THE CHAMBER TO
PRESENT EIGHTY FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH
WILL REQUIRE TALENT AGENCIES TO
TRAIN THEIR STAFF IN THE ARTISTS
THEY REPRESENT. IN AN APPROVED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
HEALTH STANDARDS PROGRAM. THIS
LEGISLATION IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER AFTER THE RECENT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SCANDALS THAT
HAVE COME TO LIGHT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
TOWN AGENCIES TO BE EMPLOYERS
AND INSTEAD REQUIRES THEM TO
ADVISE THE TALENT.
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO ACT
THIS YEAR TO PROTECT TALENT AND
DEVELOP PREVENTATIVE METHODS.
THESE PROFESSIONAL SAFE IN THEIR
WORKING ENVIRONMENT
HERE'S TO SPEAK ON THE BILL AYE
HAVE SARAH'S IF THE FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE MODEL ALLIANCE.
CARRY OTIS SUTTON A FORMER
ACTRESS AND MODEL AND KRISTIN
SNOW OF THE NATIONAL EATING
DISORDERS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING WITH ME TODAY. IS
THAT.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
.
I I AM HERE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH LAYS
OUT IMPORTANT REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE LONG OVERDUE TO PREVENT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND EATING
DISORDERS. IN THE MODELING AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRIES.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT IN
THESE INDUSTRIES IS RAMPANT.
I KNOW THIS FIRST HAND AFTER
WORKING AS A MODEL SINCE I WAS
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD.
UNFORTUNATELY THE AGENTS WHO
SHOULD BE OUR FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE CAN SOMETIMES BE
COMPLICIT IN THESE ABUSES.
AND SOME AGENTS EVEN EXHIBIT
PREDATORY BEHAVIOR THEMSELVES.
IN MY TWO DECADES WORKING AS A
MODEL. I NEVER RECEIVED TRAINING
ABOUT WHAT CONSTITUTES WORKPLACE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. OR GUIDANCE
ABOUT HOW TO REPORT ABUSE.
QUITE THE OPPOSITE AS A TEENAGER
I WAS MADE TO SIT ON MY MUCH
OLDER MALE AGENTS LACK DURING
OUR MEETINGS AT THE AGENCY.
I WAS ROUTINELY SENT TO
SURPRISE NUDE SHOOTS AND
CASTINGS EVEN AFTER COMPLAINING
ABOUT THIS TO MY AGENCY.
ON MORE THAN ONE OCCASION MY
AGENCY ARRANGED MEETINGS AT THE
APARTMENTS OR HOTEL ROOMS OF
MUCH OLDER MEN.
AND UPON ARRIVAL IT BECAME CLEAR
THAT THERE WAS NO JOB.
I WAS FORCED TO NAVIGATE
FENDING OFF UNWANTED ADVANCES
WITHOUT RUINING MY CAREER.
WHEN I BROUGHT MY CONCERNS TO
THE PRESIDENT OF ONE AGENCY
ABOUT A WELL KNOWN PHOTOGRAPHER
HE SHRUGGED AND SUGGESTED I WAS
BEING UPTIGHT.
SHORTLYTHEREAFTER I LEFT THE
AGENCY AND THE PHOTOGRAPHER IS
NOW BEING INVESTIGATED BY THE
NYPD SPECIAL VICTIMS UNIT FOR
NUMEROUS ALLEGATIONS BY MODELS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SITUATIONS THAT WOULD CLEARLY
CONSTITUTE SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
AN OFFICE SETTING ARE LESS EASY
TO NAVIGATE IN THE MODELING
ENTERTAINMENT HISTORIES. BUT
JUST BECAUSE THE LINES ARE MORE
DIFFICULT TO DRAW IT DOES NOT
MAKE IT ANY MORE OKAYED ACROSS
THEM.
I AGENCIES EXERT A GREAT DEAL OF
CONTROL OVER THEIR TALENTS
WORKING LIVES AND SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO TURN A BLIND EYE TO
ABUSE OF THE PEOPLE WHOSE
INTERESTS THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
REPRESENT.
RATHER AGENCIES SHOULD
PROACTIVELY TAKE STEPS TO
PREVENT THESE ABUES.
EATING DISORDERS ARE ALSO A
MAJOR ISSUE WITH RESEARCHERS AT
HARVARD AT HARVARD IN
NORTHEASTERN UNIVERSITY'S THE
MODEL LANCE CONDUCTED THE
LARGEST STUDY TO DATE ON EATING
DISORDERS AMONGST PROFESSIONAL
MODELS.
THE STUDY CONFIRMED THAT MODELS
ARE OFTEN PRESSURE TO LOSE
WEIGHT AND JEOPARDY RIGHT
JEOPARDIZE THEIR HEALTH IN ORDER
TO BiC JOBS.
WE FOUND A HIGH PREVALENCE OF
UNHEALTHY WEIGHT CONTROL
BEHAVIOR SUCH AS FASTS
DETOX IS USING DIET PILLS AND
COCAINE. AND VOMITING.
AMONG THE MODEL SURVEYED OVER
EIGHTY PERCENT WERE CLASSIFIED
AS UNDERWEIGHT.
AND YET THESE MODELS REPORTED
BEING PRESSURED BY THERE
AGENCIES TO LOSE MORE WEIGHT.
OVER HALF OF THE MODELS WERE
ASKED TO LOSE WEIGHT OR CHNGE
THEIR SHAPE. AND TWENTY ONE
PERCENT WERE TOLD THEIR AGENCY
WOULD STOP REPRESENTING THEM
UNLESS THEY LOST WEIGHT.
BEING DANGEROUSLY UNDERWEIGHT
AND HAVING AN EATING DISORDER
CAN HAVE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES ON
A YOUNG PERSON'S GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT CAN AFFECT THEM
FOR LIFE.
IN RECENT YEARS SEVERAL MODELS
WHO REPORTEDLY SUFFERED FROM
EATING DISORDERS HAVE DIED. IN
SOME CASES WITHIN MINUTES OF
STEPPING OFF A RUNWAY.
THE PRESSURES FROM AGENCIES TO
ENGAGE IN UNHEALTHY WEIGHT
CONTROL BEHAVIORS IS A SERIOUS
LABOR ISSUE THAT MUST BE
RECOGNIZED AND TREATED AS SUCH.
FURTHER THERE IS OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE.
THAT BEING A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT INCREASES THE RISK OF
DEVELOPING AN EATING DISORDER.
GIVEN THE CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN SEXUAL ABUSE AND EATING
DISORDERS IT IS APPROPRIATE
INDEED NECESSARY. THAT THESE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED TOGETHER.
BY CREATING WHO PROACTIVE
REQUIREMENTS WE AIM TO ESTABLISH
A SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. AND
THIS WILL CREATE A WORKPLACE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE POTENTIAL
VICTIMS HAVE BEEN EMPOWERED WITH
AWARENESS OF THEIR RIGHTS AND
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY IN CASES
OF ABUSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I AGAIN
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING YOU TODAY
MY NAME IS CARRIE OWED A SUDDEN
AND I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
CALIFORNIA.
FOR NEARLY THREE DECADES I'VE
WORKED IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY BOTH AS A MODEL ACTOR
AND AUTHOR.
IN THAT TIME I'VE INTO WERE
COUNTLESS EXPERIENCES OF BOTH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
AT THE AGE OF SIXTEEN I WAS
REPEATEDLY ASSAULTED AND RAPED
BY MY THEN AGENT.
IT WAS MADE CLEAR TO ME THAT IF
I WERE TO COMPLAIN OR REPORT
THESE ASSAULTS IT WOULD MEAN THE
END OF MY CAREER.
I WAS ADVISED THAT IF I WANTED
TO SUCCEED AS A MODEL I WOULD
NEED TO TOUGHEN UP. WHICH
BASICALLY MEANT BITING MY
TONGUE.
AND ALLOWINGINFLUENTIAL MEN IN
THE INDUSTRY TO ABUSE THEIR
POWER.
AND I REFUSED STAY SILENT ANY
LONGER.
THROUGHOUT MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE
IN THIS INDUSTRY I'VE
EXPERIENCED SEXUAL HARASSMENT SO
OFTEN.
AND IN SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT PREDATORY AND ABUSIVE
BEHAVIOR WAS NORMALIZED.
SADLY I CAME TO ACCEPT THAT
THESE WERE MY WORKING
CONDITIONS.
OVER THIRTY YEARS NOT ONE SINGLE
AGENT EVER TOLD ME OTHERWISE.
NOR WAS I EVER EMPOWER TO SPEAK
UP OR TOLD THAT I COULD REPORT
THESE ABUSES.
THE COMBINATION OF THESE
OFFENSES RESULTED IN DEEP TRAUMA
THAT LED TO YEARS OF ANOREXIA.
ALTHOUGH I WAS OUT APPROVED OUT
RELEASE SUCCESSFUL IS A MODEL IN
AFTER WORKING AS A FACE OF SOME
OF THE BIGGEST BRANDS.
I WAS PRIVATELY BATTLING A DO
DEBILITATING ILLNESS AND I HAD
TO UNDERGO HEART SURGERY AT AGE
THIRTY.
AS A RESULT OF MY EATING
DISORDER.
MY EXPERIENCE IS NOT UNIQUE THE
REVELATIONS OF THE WINE STEEN
SCANDAL THESE LAST FEW MONTHS
HAVE MADE CLEAR. THAT I AM NOT
ALONE.
COUNTLESS WOMEN IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS ARE
SHARING THEIR STORIES OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF COMPANIES
IMPLEMENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING.
FOR EXAMPLE ALL PUBLICLY TRADED
COMPANIES MANDATE THAT EACH
EMPLOYEE INCLUDING EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP.
PARTICIPATE AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING TWICE A
YEAR.
CURRENTLY MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND LEADING COMPANIES
ADHERE TO THESE STANDARDS.
IN AN INDUSTRY THE COMMODIFIED
SEX APPEAL AND REGULARLY
EMPLOYEES VULNERABLE YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS IT'S UNACCEPTABLE
FOR AGENCIES NOT TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
MODELING AGENCY SO YOU SHOULD
NOT BE EXEMPTED FROM PROTECTING
THEIR WORKERS AND ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE TREATED WITH DIGNITY.
AND RESPECT AND IN MANY CASES
THESE AGENCIES OF THE FIRST AND
SOMETIMES ONLY LINE OF DEFENSE
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS
WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT AGENCIES
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PROTECTING
THIS MOST VULNERABLE FORCE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY SEEN COUNTLESS
EXAMPLES OF HOW UBIQUITOUS THIS
PREDATORY BEHAVIORS ARE IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
AND DIGNITY OF MODELS ACTORS AND
OTHER ARTISTS WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FIX WITH.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KRISTEN
SNOW AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL EATING
DISORDERS ASSOCIATION. OR NITA.
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU TO CHAIRMAN THURMAN
AND ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ON LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
IN ADDITION TO BEING A PROUD
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS AT THE
NATIONAL EATING DISORDERS
ASSOCIATION.
WHICH IS THE LARGEST NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
AFFECTED BY EATING DISORDERS.
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO APPROVE A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND HEALTH
STANDARDS TRAINING PROGRAM.
AND REQUIRE TALENT AGENCIES TO
ENSURE THE ARTISTS THEY
REPRESENT RECEIVED THE DEVELOP
TRAINING.
THE NATIONAL EATING DISORDERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORTS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC LEVINE FOR
SPONSORSHIP AND LEADERSHIP AND
CHAMPIONING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. AND I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS
INITIATIVE.
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HEALTH STANDARDS
TRAINING PROGRAM WOULD REDUCE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE FASHION
INDUSTRY. AS WELL AS THE
PREVALENCE OF EATING DISORDERS
WHICH ARE CLOSELY LINKED.
DRAMATIC EXPERIENCES SUCH AS
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR HARASSMENT
HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT RISK FACTOR FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EATING DISORDERS.
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT WOMEN WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF ASSAULT WERE
ALMOST TWO TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
DEVELOP BULIMIA THAN THOSE WHO
HAD NOT BEEN VICTIMIZED.
FURTHERMORE MODELS EXPERIENCE A
SUBSTANTIALLY ELEVATED RISK OF
EATING DISORDERS BECAUSE OF
EXPECTATIONS PLACED UPON THEM TO
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN BODY WEIGHT.
NEARLY THIRTY MILLION AMERICANS
WILL SUFFER FROM AN EATING
DISORDER AT SOME POINT IN THEIR
LIFE AND IN CALIFORNIA THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE CURRENTLY
STRUGGLING WITH AN EATING
DISORDER. IS ESTIMATED TO BE
OVER ONE MILLION INDIVIDUALS.
EATING DISORDERS DO NOT
DISCRIMINATE THE AFFECT ALL
PEOPLE OF ALL GENDERS RACES AGES
AND SOCIO ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS.
EATING DISORDERSUCH AS ANOREXIA
NERVOSA BINGE EATING DISORDER
AND BULIMIA NERVOSA ARE COMPLEX
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS WHICH
LEAD TO CHRONIC HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS.
AND THEY HAVE THE HIGHEST
MORTALITY RATE OF ANY MENTAL
ILLNESS.
FOR FEMALES BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD WHO SUFFER
FROM ANOREXIA THE MORTALITY RATE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ILLNESS IS
TWELVE TIMES HIGHER THEN THE
DEATH RATE OF ALL OTHER CAUSES
OF DEATH.
FURTHERMORE.
RISK OF DEATH FROM SUICIDE ARE
MEANT MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS IS
MARKEDLY INCREASED FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH EATING
DISORDERS.
ALTHOUGH QUITE SERIOUS EATING
DISORDERS CAN BE PREVENTED WE
BELIEVE THAT THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND HEALTH STANDARDS
TRAINING PROGRAM WOULD HAVE A
MAJOR IMPACT. IN THE PREVENTION
OF BOTH SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
EATING DISORDERS IN THE FASHION
INDUSTRY.
THE REQUIREMENTS LAID OUT IN AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEX ARE LONG
OVERDUE.
IT IS TIME THAT WE WORK TOGETHER
TO IMPLEMENT THESE IMPORTANT
PROTECT.
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA LEADER IN PROTECTING
MODELS AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
FASHION INDUSTRY FROM THESE
DANGEROUS ILLNESS AS.
WE AT THE NATIONAL EATING
DISORDERS ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
JUST SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES AND THANK THE
WITNESSES WHO SHARED VERY
PERSONAL AND DIFFICULT
EXPERIENCES SADDENED NAY WERE
SADDENED TO HEAR THAT THESE HAVE
OCCURRED BUT WE ARE THANKFUL FOR
THE COURAGE IN AND AND RAISING
THEM TO THE SURFACE.
THIS COMMITTEE ALWAYS WELCOMES
THOSE WHO WILLINGLY SHARE THINGS
PUBLICLY OR PRIVATELY
AND THAT WILL HELP TO PROTECT OF
THOSE IN A WORKFORCE IN EVERY
SECTOR
THANK YOU.
ARE NOW CALLING ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE.
I'M SORRY IT WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITION FIRST.
DO WE HAVE THAT WE HAVE ANYONE
WISHING TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
IF IT'S APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME
CHAIRMAN I'M I'M CARE STUART AND
FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF TALENT
AGENTS.
WE SUPPORT IF AMENDED I SEE. SO
IF I IT THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATE
AT THIS TIME WAITING TO TELL ME
THAT NOW LONG MEETINGS THIS WEEK
TO TALK ABOUT NOT HOT BUT NOT.
OF OF COURSE IT IS WELCOME. WHEN
I SAW YOU STAND ABOUT THAT YOU
WERE COMING TO PRESENT
OPPOSITION
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR SUPPORT
IF AMEND PASSAIC YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. OF I REPRESENT
THE ASSOCIATION OF TALENT AGENTS
IT'S AN EIGHTY YEAR OLD TRADE
ASSOCIATION I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
I APPRECIATE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE OF THIS
IS AN EXPEDITED BILL AND OF
COURSE THE CHAIRMAN IS RIGHT WE
DID SPEAK ABOUT THIS BILL THE
OTHER DAY. SO BECAUSE IT HAS
BEEN A RUSH.
I WANT TO PLEASE READ IF I MAY
AND A LETTER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME TO THE
TABLE TO MAKE A STATEMENT
WHATEVER YOU BELIEVE SOME
PROPRIA UP WE WELCOME YOU WE
WELCOME.
SO AS I SAID. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF TALENT
AGENTS.
AND.
WE ARE A NONPROFIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION A WE REPRESENT OVER
A HUNDRED TALENT AGENCIES
LICENSED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THOSE TALENT
AGENCIES PROBABLY REPRESENT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF WORKING ARTISTS
TODAY.
OUR MEMBER AGENCIES REPRESENT
DIRECTORS WRITERS AND OTHER
ARTISTS IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
ENTERPRISES INCLUDING MODELS.
AND ALL OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE TO
BE LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
THE CURRENT TALENT AGENCIES ACT.
ATA DESIRES TO SUPPORT EIGHTY BE
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX IF AMENDED
AND TAKES VERY SERIOUSLY THE
ISSUE OF SAFE WORKING CONDITIONS
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
UNIONS THE GUILDS ALONG WITH
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY TO
DEVELOP AN INDUSTRY WIDE
SOLUTION.
THAT NOT ONLY FOSTERS A SAFE
WORKING ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO
ADDRESSES THE COMPLEX
INSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGES.
GIVEN THE EXPEDITED SCHEDULE AND
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL WE
ARE VERY ENCOURAGED BY OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE. AND HAVE
BEEN GIVEN ASSURANCES THAT IN
THE CURRENT FORM EIGHT BE
SEVENTY EIGHT YEAH I'M SORRY AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX IS NOT IN
FINAL FORM AND HE LOOKS FORWARD
TO PARDONING WITH PTA. TO
PERFECT THE BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS.
I DO WANT TO MENTION SOME
SPECIFIC CONCERNS OF THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE BILL THAT SEEKS TO
ESTABLISH A NEW HEALTH STANDARD
FOR MODELS WHILE EMPLOYING
PROVISIONS NEARLY IDENTICAL TO
THOSE CONTAINED IN AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY NINE. OH ALSO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND THE
ASSEMBLY REJECTED THIS BILL IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
SPECIFICALLY AB FIFTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX REQUIRES THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD CAL OSHA. TO
ADOPT AN OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARD FOR MODELS.
TO DEAL WITH THE PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT OF EATING DISORDERS.
THE BILL CONTAINS NO REAL
DEFINITION FOR WHAT CONSTITUTES
HEALTHY AND WE BELIEVE IT CAN
ENCOURAGE POSSIBLE
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ARTISTS.
IF THEY FALL OUTSIDE OF WHATEVER
THIS AMBIGUOUS HEALTHY LABEL IS.
BUT ATA AND OUR MEMBERS STRONGLY
AGREE THE PROFESSIONAL FASHION
MODELS LIKE ALL WORKERS ARE
ENTITLED TO SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT AB SET
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX MAY MAKE A
MISTAKE IN THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE MODELS AND THE
AGENTS.
BUT WE REALLY SEEK TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH OUR INDUSTRY
PARTNERS OTHER CONCERN LAWMAKERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE MODELS
ALLIANCE.
IN AN EFFORT TO ACHIEVE THE
IMPORTANT UNDERLYING OBJECTIVES
OF WHAT WE BELIEVE ARE CONTAINED
IN MAYBE FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON
IN SUPPORT OR SUPPORT IF
AMENDED.
THANK YOU CNN RECALL ANY
OPPOSITION.
THE OPPOSITION TODAY.
SEEING NONE OUT UNDER THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE BECAUSE I
DON'T.
YOU AGREE THAT HER STATEMENT IS
RIGHT THAT YOU HAVE MADE.
ASSERTIONS THAT THIS BILL IS
NOT.
POLICY WISE WHERE IT'S GONNA END
UP AND THAT YOU'RE GOING TO WORK
WITH.
THE TALENT AGENCIES I THINK IT'S
A THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION I
THINK IT'S A OF IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO SAY WHAT I'VE SAID BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS WHICH IS UP FOR
SMALL I'M GRATEFUL FOR MS
STEWART SUPPORT. IF AMENDED
POSITION FOR HER AGENCY I HAVE
ASSURED HER THAT TO I SEE HER
AGENCY AS A UP HER ASSOCIATION
AS A PARTNER IN THE BILL. AND
THAT WE WILL.
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION BOTH
THE FEEDBACK FROM HER MEMBERSHIP
BUT ALSO THE MEMBERSHIP OF THIS
BODY.
AS WE GO FORWARD WITH THIS BILL
BECAUSE SIDE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT TAD BOTH THAT
THERE IS A POLITICAL SPOTLIGHT
ON THIS ISSUE THAT SHOULD NOT.
INFORMED THE POLICY IN A VACUUM
OF GETTING THE POLICY RIGHT AND
HAVE IT WORK WELL FOR BOTH THE
TALENT AND THE AGENCIES.
I AM I'M A SUPPORT THIS TODAY AS
I TOLD YOU I WOULD THESE IN AND
JUST BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT MY
CONCERNS BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THE
TIMING.
I BELIEVE THIS IF PASCO'S GO
PREPARATIONS.
AND.
WOULD BE.
MOVED IN OR OUT BY NEXT WEEK.
I HAVE EX
STREAM CONCERNS ABOUT MOVING A
BILL THAT POLICY REALLY NEEDS BE
DEVELOPED OUT OF THIS HOUSE
S. B. FORTS DEVELOP IN THE
POLICY COMMITTEE IN THIS.
AND I UNDERSTAND I MEAN WE ALL
OF.
MAKE DECISIONS ON WHERE TO PUT
OUR BILLS FOR DIFFERENT REASONS
AND I'M. I'M THE SAME WAY I'M
GONNA GO EXPLAIN IT I REALLY
THINK THIS BILL SHOULD I STARTED
AS A FRESH BELL. I'M I THINK
THAT THERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
AND CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
THAT ARE REALISTIC AND.
NEED SOME VETTING I THINK IT'S
TOO IMPORTANT VINICIO TOTO RUSH
IT THROUGH.
IN IT IN A WAY THAT THAT
THERE'S THESE OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS ONE THAT I HAD OR ONE
CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THOSE IN
THE INDUSTRY WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE DON'T EVEN HAVE
AGENCY REPRESENTATION.
AND SO WE HAVE.
AT.
WE WORK FOR TACKLING
A PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS
PROBABLY THE MOST SUCCESSFUL IN
AND THE BUSINESS AND NOT THOSE
WHO ARE ARE TRYING TO ENTER THE
BUSINESS AND SOMETIMES ARE ARE
PULLED. HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA
OF THEIR RIGHTS AS WELL I THINK
ALL WORKERS SHOULD BE INFORMED
OF THEIR RIGHTS NOT SOMETHING WE
TALKED ABOUT MY AND I'M LOOKING
AT ANOTHER BILLS IS WE DON'T IN
THE UNITED STATES EVER INFORM
WORKERS ANY WORKERS.
OF WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE IN THE
WORKPLACE.
BUT WHAT THEY'RE RIGHT WHERE
THEY GO TO REPORT THOSE RIGHTS
MINIMUM COME FROM LABOR THIS IS
LIKE A HUGE ISSUE AND ONE WHICH
I THINK WE'VE GOT TO GET RIGHT.
AND IT'S NOT JUST IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT STREETS ONE OF
MANY MANY INDUSTRIES.
THAT.
WE'RE TRYING TO KIND OF FIGURE
OUT AND I'M STILL UNSURE WHY.
.
IN MOST INDUSTRIES WHEN WE LOOK
AT THAT SWEET REALLY LOOK AT THE
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE
RELATIONSHIP
RIGHT AND OF COURSE THIS AGENT
THIS.
INDUSTRY IS SO DIFFERENT THAN
THE TYPICAL EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONSHIP AM VERY AWARE. OF
OF THAT
IN IN SO WERE PUTTING AN ONUS ON
REPRESENTATION AND AGENCIES.
THAT NORMALLY WE REPLACE SEEN ON
EMPLOYERS
I'M AND I KIND OF LIKEN IT TO.
YOU KNOW I I THINK WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH.
.
WITH CONCUSSIONS IN THE NFL AND
SO IF I WOULD WANT TO DO A BILL
ON THAT WHICH I MIGHT OR MIGHT
NOT HAVE DONE.
THAT WE WE WOULD GO.
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT THE NFL OR
OR WORLD FOOTBALL OR COLLEGE
FOOTBALL CHANGES THEIR
PRACTICES.
AND NOT GO TOWARDS SPORTS AGENTS
TO REQUIRE THEM TO SOMEHOW
CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES.
AND HAVE AN UPWARD PUSH ON THE
EMPLOYER NOW NOT TOTALLY
CONVINCED OF MY OWN ARGUMENT
BECAUSE. WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A POWER STRUCTURE WHERE
WHERE WORKERS HAVE THE LEAST
AMOUNT POWER IN AND I'M CONSUMER
LEAVING OUT? THE LOWEST.
EMPOWERED WORKERS I DON'T HAVE
REPRESENTATION THEY HAVE WORKERS
WITH REPRESENTATION THEN YOU
HAVE THE REPRESENTATION KIND
HAVE THIS OTHER SPOT AND THEN
YOU HAVE THE EMPLOYER'S RIGHT
WITH WITH. YOU KNOW OF A FASHION
HOUSE DECIDES THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE MODELS AT A CERTAIN WEIGHT.
THERE'S NOT A LOT THE AGENT CAN
DO IT NOW
RIGHT SO WHAT WE'RE HAVING.
OR CERTAIN LOOK.
IT'S COMPLICATED AND THAT'S WHY
I SUGGEST THAT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT.
TO HAVE THE THE.
TONE AGENCIES INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING SOMETHING THAT THEY
WILL WORK WITH HOPEFULLY AND I
WOULD EXPECT THIS WITH.
WITH THE TALENT TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT WORKS AND KIND OF
PUT SOME IN CONJUNCTION AND HAS
THEM FIGHTING TOGETHER AGAINST
KIND OF THIS INDUSTRY THAT'S
VERY SPECIAL INDUSTRY WHICH IS
AFFECTING NOT ONLY THE WORKERS
AND INDUSTRY BUT ALSO HOW EVERY
LITTLE GIRL. INVOICE SEE
THEMSELVES AS AS THEY SEE A
REFLECTION IN IT SO. GIVEN NOT.
BUT THE LOT THERE. IT WE GOT A
WEEK.
SO IF YOU REALLY WANT I'M I'M TO
VOTE FOR THIS AND I HOPE IT
MOVES FORWARD. AND YOU NOW AYE
AYE WERE NOT EXPERTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE I I JUST I'M NOT.
THERE AT THE I'M GIVING YOU A
WARNING THAT I DON'T USUALLY
GIVE PEOPLE YOU HOW I'M NOT
THERE OF OF MOVING A BILL THAT
HAS SO MANY POLICY IMPLICATIONS.
OUT OF THIS HOUSE.
SO QUICKLY IF WE CAN'T COME TO
SOMETHING WITH AND SO I I HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE YOU START.
ON THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
RIGHT AFTER THIS COMMITTEE IF
THEY YEAH I SHOULD JUST SHUT UP
BECAUSE YOU SAID YOU GONNA VOTE
FOR IN COMMITTEE BUT.
.
I THINK IT.
YEAH I KNOW THAT.
SHE RAISES A LOT OF IMPORTANT
ISSUES WHERE.
I THINK THIS PRIDE OF LIKE
WHAT WORK MUST TAKE PLACE IN
THIS HOUSE VERSUS THE FACT THAT.
ANY OF YOU AT ANY POINT AND TIME
IN THE LIFE OF THIS BILL. ARE
WELCOME
TO OUT WEIGH IN. ON HOW TO MAKE
THIS WORK RIGHT NOT JUST YOU
KNOW ON THE AGENCY'S BEHALF.
BUT BUT FOR THE PROTECTION OF
OF EVERYBODY.
AND THAT DOESN'T STOP THERE'S
NO EXPIRATION DATE ON THAT SO I
I APPRECIATE THAT CONCERN.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED IS HER SECOND.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR.
THREE.
WITNESSES WHO PROVIDED
TESTIMONY IN PAINFUL TESTIMONY
THAT.
IT SHOWS
THAT NO MATTER WHERE YOU ARE IN
YOUR SUCCESS.
YOU CAN BE OF VICTIM.
AND IT'S
IT IN YOUR VULNERABLE.
AND
EVEN IF.
YOU MEET.
A SOCIETY OR MEDIA SUBJECTIVE
STANDARD OF BEAUTY.
THAT THAT VULNERABILITY.
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND AND WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WEIGH EN AND SAY THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD BE PROTECTED
EVERY MAN AND WOMAN.
IN THIS ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
IN IN THE SECTOR AYE IS
DESERVING OF THAT DIGNITY.
AND THAT PROTECTION
AND I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE CLEARLY OF MUCH IS
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO ADDRESS
BOTH SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
ACTUAL SALT.
AND EATING DISORDERS AND SO WE
APPLIED TO YOU IN THAT EFFORT.
WE ALSO TAKE IT TO HEART T.
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
AGENCIES AND WORK WITHIN THE
TIMELINE THAT WAS DISCUSS TODAY.
BECAUSE THESE ARE REALLY COMPLEX
ISSUES AND IT'S A DIFFERENT
SECTOR THAN OTHER SECTORS IN.
AND SO THE CONVERSATION NEEDS
TO BE BROAD IMBALANCE FOR AGENTS
IN EMPLOYERS IN THOSE WHO WERE A
WHO ARE INFECTED SO.
THE BILL ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER I HOPE
WE CAN WORK IT OUT AYE FOR NOW
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE CHU. CHU AYE MELENDEZ.
LENDERS AYE.
ELIZABETH.
IT'S YOU CAN MISS THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH RESEARCHER
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ABOUT IT'S THE FINAL ITEM THAT
WE HAVE BEFORE US THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED